are you getting knocked down over and
over again are you burning through
fairies faster than you can say Triforce
of courage even after dropping a few G's
on a shiny new set of armor and
investing in hearts you can still get
your butt kicked by some of the deadlier
creatures that roam Hyrule if this
sounds familiar it might be time for you
to hit up the rest of those great fairy
fountains keep in mind that these fairy
fountains can get a bit pricey so you
might want to check out our money making
guide first you've probably found the
first one by now if not head to Kakariko
village of shrine and you can find the
great fairy in this little forest right
behind it for the low low price of 100
rupees you can restore her power and
start upgrading your clothing and armor
the fountain will grant you access to
level 1 upgrades most armor you find
will have a base defense of 3 once you
upgraded here it will increase to 5 I'd
recommend hitting up the tube anther
region next before we head over to the
great fairy fountain though let's make a
pit stop it to bantha bridge stable here
you can find tauren talk to him and
he'll ask you to give the great fairy a
500 rupee offering lucky for us the
second fairy will ask for exactly 500
rupees in order to restore her power
once you've scaled the tower in the
region look to the south and you should
see the fountain from here an armor set
with the base defense of three will
increase to 8 with the level 2 upgrade
[Music]
the next fountain you will probably come
across is south of Tarrytown or on the
east shore of Lake Acala if you can't
find Tarrytown on your map that might be
because it doesn't exist yet if you want
to know how to build Tarrytown check out
our how to buy a house video this
fountain will cost you a thousand rubies
so hopefully you've accrued a bit more
cash at this point an Armour set with
the base defense of three will increase
the 12 with a level 3 upgrade now it's
time for the fourth and final great
fairy fountain this one is probably the
hardest one to get to see that sandstorm
to the south west of Gerudo village good
because that's where we're going once
you've stocked up on supplies let's head
out keep in mind that once you've
stepped foot in the storm you cannot
check your map so keep heading southeast
until the storm clears and look for
these Leviathan bones they are pretty
tough to miss underneath you can find
the fourth and final fountain but don't
celebrate yet
this fountain will cost you wait for it
10,000 rupees make sure to complete the
nearby shrine so you can war back here
once you have enough money this ferry
will allow you to upgrade your armor to
level 4 meaning that armor sets that
have a base defense of 3 will now be at
20
you don't have to follow this order when
unlocking the Fountains the first will
always cost you 100 the second 500 the
third 1000 and the final 10,000 certain
armor sets will also give you perks as
you upgrade them unfortunately the
Hylian set which I'm using right now
does not there's still a lot we don't
know about breath of the wild so if you
find anything cool leave a comment below
and make sure to subscribe thanks for
watching
[Music]